welcome back to the 53rd ever
iced coffee hour i'm your boy protodoge
and we have made so far
62 761.
oh my god i have to say that's that's
the best we've ever seen we're getting
really comfortable
i'm starting to get better at this right
you're the first person by the way we've
ever had on the podcast
back to back this has never happened
really that's crazy
and for good reason this last podcast
beat our analytics
like times two of our last that's the
message the funny thing is okay so the
last one we did right
you know how i did the intro yeah i was
totally joking when i did that and then
you guys were like we're keeping it
we're keeping i was like oh
i guess i guess we're keeping that one
like i wasn't even yeah i was joking
around
what's crazy about both of these
episodes both of them were last minute
so we had no idea we were gonna film
last week's episode
until maybe like five minutes before
yeah we're like should we do it okay we
may as well do it yeah and this episode
too it was a last minute
thing it's like we just happened to be
in town today you're here
we may as well just film an episode
because some crazy stuff happened
snl happened yes the price dropped 40
percent
yes very quickly i fluctuated a million
dollars within that hour
you lost a million dollars in an hour
but first i want to thank our sponsor
raid shadow legends
go ahead and stop that dogecoin buy
order that you're about to submit we
need to talk about something much bigger
than that have you taken down the demon
lord yet yeah i didn't think so
what about the ice golem have you
completely destroyed that i didn't think
so either okay well
surely you've ascended the doom tower oh
my gosh you haven't well prepare for
battle because you can do all of this
and even fight against the millions of
real players in the arena with rage
shadow
legends with hundreds of artifacts to
equip and over 500
champions blessed with unique skills you
can build your team develop your
champions and raid your way use the link
below to download raid to your mobile
phone or pc oh my gosh
there's a hound spawn a champion from
the demon spawn faction
it's basically bailey if she had awesome
superpowers
whoa the houndspawn brought me a shard
what i like most about raid is that you
have so many different factions to
choose from
to match your exact playing style once
you find a faction that you like you can
choose from any of the champions there
personally i'll be sticking with the
hound spawn because it reminds me of
bayley
and this month alone raid released 11
new champions 200 new missions with an
exclusive champion if you manage to
finish them all
and 5 new levels to almost every single
dungeon in the game
every month raid adds new content that
makes it bigger and better and it's
never been easier to get started and
once you're in the game you can find me
under the username options master and if
you're quick enough you can even join my
clan
just click the link in the description
to get started and i will see you in the
game
thank you so much raid for sponsoring
this episode and back to the podcast
yeah and it was up in the very beginning
it was that i remember it shot up
right before they started talking about
it to maybe 2.7 million 2.8 million i
was sitting at
and within maybe 20 30 minutes it
dropped down to 1.8 million like nothing
wow what was that like it was uh it was
a little you know
it was a little nerve-wracking it was a
little uh i had my phone up just looking
at it and i was like i'm gonna show
everybody this like everybody's gonna
see this and i don't know what they're
gonna say they're gonna call me an idiot
they're gonna call me crazy they're
gonna say whatever they want but
this is the reality of it i can't just
show the gains you know i got to show
the losses too
and in hindsight looking back on it is
that something you would have expected
to happen
when they did snl with dogecoin it's
funny because i actually did a video on
my youtube channel the dogecoin
millionaire
and in that video right before elon went
on i said i just have a feeling it's
going to dip
i have a feeling it's going to dip it
happened on doge day there was all this
build up to doge day 4 20. i don't know
if you guys remember that
but days before it shot up went up up up
up those day happens
crashes down and it's like okay now we
got to build it back up
and then elon musk on snow's another one
of those things that happened was like
everybody's looking forward to it so
leading up to it it's going up up up
up and then crashes down you know what i
mean so it was kind of predictable in a
little way
what do you think of the actual episode
itself did you think it did
justice for dogecoin oh the jokes were
the jokes funny
i think it did what it had to do and the
reason why i say that is because
it brought awareness to dogecoin so
there are probably people out there that
were watching saturday night live
that didn't know what those coin was up
until that point and so
if you put it in more people's faces if
you just say hey those going doors going
like
that can only be a positive in my
opinion yeah i didn't like the episode
at all i watched it i was
like not a single skit uh no
really i i didn't get i didn't get the
jokes i was sitting there
at dinner with with kevin and we had snl
on and then we had the price of dogecoin
i know i saw that
i saw it and we were just watching the
episode here watching the price of
dogecoin
goes to commercial break the price
immediately drops yeah elon musk comes
back down you see the price is starting
to go yeah yeah
it's so crazy wild to watch that and
then after every skit
sell off every schedule you know you
know where the first sell-off was
the first sell-off was when elon's mom
showed up
and then she was like hopefully mother's
day is coming out rash is like i hope
you don't pay me in dogecoin and then
elon's like
i am you know what i mean she didn't
want it yeah exactly
that's what it was so it was like oh
wait huh i don't you know what i mean
like it was the whole thing
yeah no i didn't think it was that good
and i'm not sure what people were
expecting if they honestly thought that
elon musk would be like well you know
starting today we're going to be
accepting
dogecoins as payment for the cars you
want to know something funny
i thought that could have been one of
the skits where elon's like
selling tesla for dogecoin and you know
what happened last night right yeah i
saw his tweet you want to explain it
i could talk about it yeah you posted a
video at uh what
before i posted a video at like 2 15 a.m
because the the news came out i want to
say around 1 13 a.m
1 15 a.m as soon as it happened i was
laying in bed
i was like i could either go to sleep
right now or i can do a youtube video
and i was like i gotta do a youtube
video so i literally got up threw my
clothes on sat on the couch like
like it's funny because usually my
videos are super high energy animated
but this one i was just like half asleep
i was like guys it's just a tesla dodge
coin
you can maybe get it i don't know you
know what i mean i'm doing that and then
like there's the post and i'm telling
people
go over there like hit yes hit yes you
know if you want to use those coin for
teslas
so that video you guys know what that
video is at right now and i posted it
i'm guessing 70 000 views what do you
think 50 000.
all right real time analytics
on that video it's at 80 000. oh my gosh
and i posted this at 2 am and this is
like my sixth dude your real-time juice
are
crazy can you record this wow
wow yes please start recording
uh yeah so i was going to show you this
anyway so real-time views check it out
here i'll let you do it because i don't
know how to use this
that's that is insane let's look at this
um whoops
wow so in the last really in the last
week you got 600
000 views 35 000 subscribers you just
got monetized right yeah
okay so you gotta wait for that i
haven't even signed up for adsense yet
but you gotta do that i just haven't had
the time i've been running around like
immediately because i'll tell you man uh
if you're getting 600
000 views that would be the equivalent
on dogecoin to you making
i don't know maybe ten thousand dollars
really yeah really
wow well it depends because this video
is the length of the video is the amount
yeah but it's 40k
so it's four so okay so oh let's talk
about this
where was i at when i was at the last
podcast i think it was at eight thousand
i said eight point eight or nine
thousand yeah i'm at 40 000 subscribers
today you know what's nuts is that uh
i've seen a lot of youtube channels that
are popping up now
remember how a year ago there were all
these channels making stimulus updates
yeah
and posting by the hour uh i mean kevin
was one
there's so much happening that like
every few hours here's an update this is
what nancy pelosi just said here's what
stephen newton just said now
your channel is popping up that are just
giving non-stop
you're speaking on the wrong side flip
that thing jack why didn't you say
anything earlier it was
it was facing the right side you flipped
it around because when you did your
thing
you moved the mic and then brought it
back but i had it facing the right way
so for the last seven minutes i've been
talking about yes it's all good though
i'm sure you can still hear it
anyway there are there are now youtube
channels out there making
hourly updates on dogecoin really yes
mike davis they're blowing up they're
blowing up you're joking it's
unsustainable
there's there's no way because right now
here's the thing the algorithm works in
very mysterious ways
it sees that like if there's a lot of
short-term interest in something
it's gonna start pumping that content to
everybody
it's unsustainable but in the short term
what people realize is that
if they catch on on these waves very
early on and all of a sudden they start
pumping out dogecoin content it's going
to keep recommending their page over and
over and over again that's true mike
davis is an
example of a newer channel
uh where up until a week ago you know
getting maybe like a few hundred views
of video
all of a sudden last week his views
exploded from
i think it was a few hundred views to
then 20 30 thousand views per video to a
hundred thousand views of video and it's
on basically a brand new channel
a hundred thousand views a video this is
my thing i wanna make quality content
and i want
it to have substance and to have meaning
behind every single video i do i don't
wanna just do a video just for the sake
of doing a video
if it's not important um some people
have told me i should start
doing daily updates of my portfolio like
where i'm at today you know what i mean
up of 100 000 down 100 000 or whatever
the case may be but i'm like
i feel like if i just keep flooding my
channel with just updates on my
portfolio or
or or anything that pops up then it's
just gonna lose a little bit of that
like
substance yeah so should i just start
another channel no
no don't just don't share updates share
updates on instagram
if you if you want people to see what
your portfolio is at every day
post a screenshot to instagram okay and
i'm just stick to the like concentrated
right
yeah but my my point is that like the
channel mike davis is not the only one
i've seen at least three or four other
channels out there that are making like
hourly updates of the price of dogecoin
from
eight o'clock in the morning to 12 p.m
at night guys here's what
so and so just said about about dogecoin
or they're even going into crazy
theories about dogecoin about the
meaning of certain things
mike davis i listen to one of these
things i it is
it is i hate those theories listen it's
just
junk here's the thing he made like an
eight minute video
saying uh just analyzing breaking down
the hidden message in snl about dogecoin
there was a like a like a date that
popped up was like june 13th or
something like this
he's like if we take this this date and
we apply it to this thing over here
it means this and then if we interpret
this in this way that means that elon
musk is secretly trying to tell us that
on june 13th
uh one of these years it might be this
year could be next year could be ten
years
one of these days something massive is
going to happen and all it also like
goes back to doing
june 13th apparently that date randomly
popped up
in the middle of some sort of episode
within the snl thing
and they're trying to like decode what
that means uh i don't want to play too
much
you know what let me show you i'll play
this a little bit of this in two-time
speed because
it's so unbelievable i was listening to
this
thing in my head like is this real i
almost i almost don't believe it's real
because like who would actually believe
this elon's hidden message
130 000 views in 24 hours
so that that's it what do you think of
that what do you think of that theory
um okay so i'm the type of person where
i don't one i don't discredit anything
just for the sake of discrediting it
on surface value i also don't fully
believe anything
just from hearing it the first time
right i got to do my own research
so when i first got into dogecoin there
were some
um there were some similar to that some
conspiracy theories about
oh what is the biggest wallet dh5 oh is
that
elon musk is he is he like owning a
third of all the dogecoin you know what
i mean like
i even you know thought that's what it
was too at the time and i was like there
was all these
messages encrypted all these people
saying this that in the third and i'm
like okay well i mean who knows that
could be possible
um and then i was wrong right and then
that wasn't the case so
these things you need to take with a
grain of salt like like some of it is
interesting like the the doge spelling
d-o-g-e like the first letter of every
uh song on whatever playlist he put he
put up there
that's interesting you know what i mean
uh the june 3rd june 23rd or whatever he
was talking about like
maybe it was completely random maybe
there is something but this is the thing
as far as the saturday night
as far as the saturday night live thing
to me there's
way more going on there than elon musk
that's not elon musk's show
you know what i'm saying so like he's
not gonna create the show around his
whatever his uh i don't know
purpose for dogecoin is that's not gonna
happen like he's just a guest
on a show that's already been put
together and then skits were put
together and he's saying what he needs
to say
so as far as that specifically i don't
really believe it
um but you know who knows like like
maybe he's onto something but i just
don't think the saturday night live
thing
really i don't think elon musk had that
much power i'll put it that way
as saturday night live to make the
scenes surround what he has
his agenda or whatever you know what i
mean do you think he's got some like
hidden
agenda behind it all like some cryptic
messages that he's trying to tell us
but he's trying to do it in a secret way
do you believe that
i feel like elon musk believes more in
dogecoin
than he puts on i'll put it that way
because
there have been way too many times where
he went out on a limb for dogecoin which
makes no sense for somebody to just be
trolling that hard
you know what i mean like he's not a
troll like a lot of people
you know they see those coins cause
think about it like this you got the
richest man in the world
behind a very powerful car company and
he's over here talking about joke meme
coins
right where does the credibility go when
there's other investors wanting to go
into
tesla investing or whatever the case may
be it just goes out the window
so he has to play koi like he like elon
musk has to pretend like
everything's one great big joke that
he's doing and
you shouldn't take him serious you know
what i mean but then he'll throw in
little
tidbits little like truths in there for
example the fate loves irony quote
saying that the most entertaining
outcome is usually the most likely
like why wouldn't he just leave it at uh
i just love memes
why would he add fate loves irony why
would he add all these extra little
you know things here and there i don't
know what do you guys think
jack i've been telling jack yourself for
a while jack
jack you're still holding right i paper
hands
what what about the pound wait did you
actually
you're joking no i part of me he's
completely joking he's joking no i
believe jack
this is what you're joking this is one
of the few times where i actually
i'm going to believe you i'm going to go
to uh if and if you're joking with me
then
then you got me i played your hands you
did yeah
i could tell when you were being serious
because i'm ashamed because i'm ashamed
that's why i know that's why
okay so explain this how did this happen
right so obviously i bewildered
i know but hey the the story is not over
yet okay the story is not
flabbergasted i know i know as you
should be you guys were really good
friends too
i thought we were homies i thought we
are homies probably
paper handed like a little paper head no
but it's not like that
it's not like advice i put more dogecoin
in the market for you to buy
that's what i did you should be thankful
you got the dip
i did you you you took my point the dip
that i bought by the way i bought
another 30 000 coins
a few nights ago but we'll talk about
that after this right so basically i
paper hands
what happened and uh i'm
right so he was pumping up and then it
was around 73 cents and this was the day
of
you know the incident with elon musk so
obviously i kind of knew it's going to
crash after snl i knew it was going to
happen
obviously you don't know but i kind of
had an idea it was going to happen so i
sold half
okay and i i sold don't give me that
look don't give me that
what did i say in the in the last
episode i'm like
i would sell it in a low 70 cents i
because i i didn't see it
getting you sold half at some point i
said when it hit 70 anything about 70
sell it what about the other half
the other half i messed up and i sold
basically at the lowest point possible
40 cents
no it wasn't 40 cents it was 50. but
like
essentially what happened was i was
trying to sell and on robin hood it
wasn't allowing me to sell and it kept
canceling me out and i lost like a
thousand bucks in
a matter of like i don't even know how
long like five minutes 10 15 minutes
because i kept trying to sell but it
wasn't allowing me to do it when was
that
this was during snl like this was
so after the big whale sold off yeah
robin hood didn't allow you to sell like
the servers were crashing
and i'll talk about that right
afterwards right so i had to hold on to
that and then i ended up selling
you know and i lost like a thousand
bucks but in total i turned my initial
i know good i deserve it right oh you do
i i turned that hundred dollars into it
it was like
13 and a half thousand or something like
that isn't jack the same guy that said
he was gonna hold if it dropped down to
five cents
i didn't remember this i would have sold
i'm happy that you sold at 70 something
cents i would have sold but here's the
thing here's the thing is something
sense
i'm not done okay let's go
i'm buying more okay i'm opening up an
account on binance and i'm buying more
let's
go as soon as the dip happens i'm buying
what was the point of you selling
to make money because i turned that's
100
into 13 000 because then you're gonna
pay tax on that so you're right right
off the bat 20
is gone wait wait no short term you're
paying short-term capital gains on that
right
right well we don't have to go into the
logistics yeah we do because that you're
you're looking at 37 percent
oh look no no you're not 30 percent you
know what 30 percent
yeah sure 30 that's fine i'm okay with
that as you have probably recognized
dogecoin is very cyclical
like it's low and then it goes high and
then it goes low but the low is a little
higher
time the market jack that's the worst
mistake you can possibly make and that
works both
in the crypto world and the stock world
you can't try to time it
i did time it i sold half it the highest
possible i know and then you sold the
other half at the lowest possible point
okay
okay i would have sold the entire thing
either you're all in you're all out yeah
you're all in garage
here's that i wouldn't have sold the
second part like it's one thing to say
okay i sold half at 70.
and then you hold the run and you hold
the rest that i would actually
understand
jack i'm actually more against you
selling
the other half i wanted to see what
would happen during snl
maybe it shot up to a dollar and i would
like to exit my other half at a dollar
that was my plan and it didn't do that
so i exited and i was like i need to get
out because it was crashing so i panic
sold
okay you panic sold you paper-handed
pansy
you cannot call me a paper hands after i
held on
for dear life ten months i told jack to
sell 27 cents
he told me to sell so many three five
cents told you he sold
40 yeah all the time he told me and
guess what i did
what diamond hands so when are you
buying when you buy on the dip
oh i'm opening i'm opening up an account
like right now so
you're buying today i'm not buying today
but i'm getting ready like i'm going to
load the account how much
money i don't know i haven't made my
mind up yet it depends on what
the price action of dogecoin like if it
goes down a lot then i'll buy in a lot
this interview just got intense
so i got i got two things today one
let's talk about robin hood really quick
okay uh so my understanding with
robinhood with no proof whatsoever is
that at the time
uh where it dropped so we had one big
whale who sold off i don't know how many
tens of millions of dollars they just
dumped at 74 cents that dropped the
price
that panicked a lot of people to then
say this is it
everyone wanted to sell at the same time
and what's unique with with
these exchanges is that um they each
trade at like a slightly different
price because like one exchange might
have more buyers
than let's say another exchange which
has more sellers but what happens with
rob in my understanding is that it
creates its own ecosystem of like buyers
and sellers
and when they can't match all the
sellers with buyers when there aren't
enough buyers out there kind of seizes
the system
so what ended up happening my theory
here is that everyone wanted to sell at
the same time there weren't enough
buyers of dogecoin to match with the
sellers and that caused the price
to temporarily halt until they were able
to reach that equilibrium because
otherwise would happen if everyone
wanted to sell
and there's like one person willing to
buy like 10 cents that would just crash
the values to 10 cents whatever
someone's willing to pay
and then it would create havoc in
between exchanges because you'll have
like
weeble on one side that's trading for
like 70 cents but robinhood all of a
sudden everyone's selling there and it's
15 cents
that's true so that's what i think
happened with robin hood
can we also talk about my double dutch
theory what's happening
so you saw what jack was saying right
well i wanted to make some money you
know what i mean so he sold it and then
i just wants to buy the dip and sell it
high and
buy low sell all right let's talk about
the double dutch theory okay
i came up with this this is based on my
own personal investing history okay
back when i was buying tesla back in
2019 i was
early investor without not early
investor i was
that was my earliest years of investing
um
i was buying in the tesla and putting it
was it was funny because i think i was
pretty much all in on tesla and i didn't
even realize that's what i was doing i
was like
i love tesla i'm buying tesla stock
every little bit of extra money i have
for my paychecks
tesla stock tesla stock tesla stock so
what did i do i mean maybe i had like 10
grand 20 minutes something like that
after a certain amount of time and what
happens
let's say the price goes up right and i
check my phone i'm like oh i'm up a
thousand bucks or 2 000 bucks right
it takes me like what two weeks three
weeks to come up with this i could just
sell right now and
lock in my profit right so what do i do
i sell and then i have oh great i got a
thousand bucks for 2000
right then what happens well i want to
buy back in so i try to buy back in
right
and then the price drops and i lose a
thousand bucks so i'm over here like
making a little bit losing a lot or or
making a lot and then losing a little
bit like
it was never like it was never a
a sound strategy right i was like you're
always gonna lose because you don't know
what's gonna happen right
so my whole strategy became
and like i said i always say this shout
out to jeremy man shout out to jeremy
uh he told he said this that resonated
with me in one of his videos he said
when you go into a stock you want to
look at it
like you're going to be in it anywhere
from two to five years
you never want to jump into a stock to
make a quick flip or anything like that
because you don't know what's going to
happen right
so it took me buying and selling like an
earnings call would come up right and
i'm like oh tesla probably killed it
yeah he probably killed it so
let me leave the money in and then they
were short or whatever on production and
it drops and i'm like [ __ ] i lost it
oh sorry guys no it's okay um we're just
creating extra work for alex right now
to edit that out
but something like that would happen or
for example um
uh for for example this this this really
happened like and it almost like
you you flip a coin right either i'm all
in or i take it all out right you flip a
coin i could go either way
every single time i was wrong another
time happened
uh i was like okay great let me put all
this money into tesla
and then ernie's call's about to come up
and i'm like ah there's so many reports
about tesla like
falling short let me just take the money
out because what if it drops and i'll
just buy it lower right
shoots up to 300. i'm like oh my god the
last thing that happened and this is why
i started diversifying my
stocks was cyber truck i'm like cyber
truck is gonna be the future this is
everybody's gonna love it it's gonna be
a radical design we're gonna like
love this thing right so all in on tesla
for the cyber truck right before like
the day before so what's that like 350
360 right
cyber truck happens the glass shattering
thing fiasco happens right
and it drops down to like 300 something
and i'm like oh my god i'm like i just
all right i'm done with this let me just
buy some uber i'll buy some carnival
cruise lines i'll buy
you know some of this and i just started
uh buying a little bit of everything
and it took me going through that
it was like my training wheels to
understanding that if you try to jump in
and jump out and jump in and jump out
that's what people are doing now with
crypto i have a lot of friends like the
new coin right yeah the new
dookie poo poo coin right shiba coin
yeah whatever the coin may be they're
like this is the next one
jump on it and then people lose money
make money this and it's all just hop in
hop out hop and hop out
no you pick something you believe in you
do as much research as you possibly can
it has to make sense to you and you have
to truly have faith in it
and then you buy it and you hold it for
at least
a year that's what i tell everybody the
problem with that theory though
is that you end up eventually with a
with a situation like cisco
where they saw a huge run-up during the
dot-com boom
2000 2001 this thing peaked it has still
not recovered in over 20 years it's
still trading
significantly lower than the peak it was
back in 2001. okay but was it was it a
good business was there
still around today quality sound
investment yes
yes absolutely they're one of the few
businesses overall
during the dot-com boom that is still
around today they're still in business
they're still doing well
it's just they were so overvalued in
2000 when they first came out
no that that was i don't think they
became publicly traded then
it's just during the dot-com boom that
was the point where everyone thought
okay you know what
anything internet related is going to be
the future and it turned out to be the
truth did something happen like that
with amazon
amazon was the same thing and went all
the way up and then went all the way
down amazon took
i believe it was like 12 years maybe 12
to 15 years just to get to the point it
was back at the peak in 2000
2001. sheesh yeah that's great but you
have to think
how many people actually held on because
amazon i didn't drop like 90 percent
that's true imagine losing 90 of your
investment and it does
nothing for a decade and you're thinking
you know what i'm gonna
that was a good idea let me keep buying
more
of all the companies out there a small
handful
actually ended up doing well very small
a lot of those companies just went
completely bankrupt they went bust
i believe that here's what i think i'll
and i'll put it like this
tesla is another company that i
wholeheartedly have so much faith in
and i know it's going to change the
world and i know it's going to be much
bigger than what it is right now
if i wasn't in crypto i'd probably be
like having a bunch of tesla shares
because even if it goes down because
right now it's down right right now
tesla's down right
i would continue to hold and because
it's something that i
see a future where tesla
is basically running the game when it
comes to automobiles and and everything
else they're doing spacex uh
you know the um what's the other thing
with this starlink
starling yeah all that other stuff
boring i mean that's that's not tesla
though that's that's
all connected it's like yeah in a weird
way kind of but you're not paying for
that like if you buy a tesla stock
you're not paying for stock
okay if you buy tesla stock are you
paying for spacex no
really really i feel like if there's a
big like groundbreaking thing that
spacex does it's going to affect
that the hype does but i'm not paying
for that yeah but if you're buying tesla
at this
price right now you're going to play
actually paying into like how well
tesla's actually doing it's just hype
that you're buying into if you buy right
now yeah but at least it's based on the
fundamentals of the data
oh i don't think that tesla price is
based off of tesla fundamentals right
now
way way way way way
you're paying for that let's talk about
that but tesla
do i believe tesla is overvalued as a
stock
possibly a little bit but i feel like
there's so many things happening behind
the scenes and like so many like
leaps and bounds that it's done over the
years that i feel like it's
earned a lot of that honestly
you're not paying for spacex when you
buy tesla
that's something you need to acknowledge
because because people think they're
i mean no they're not so if people think
that they're connected
then aren't they going to play a role
yeah
people think a lot of things that people
think the earth is flat that doesn't
make it
any more true i mean it's just that
they're they're wrong okay but that's a
different thing because that's not at
all people are mistaken
but certain things play into other
certain things like
drastic comparison yeah you can't make
that comparison that's not fair i can't
i just did i just didn't make that
comparison but you think that there's no
actual value in dogecoin right
but people do and it drives up the price
and a lot of people made a lot of money
so let's talk about tesla we'll make
money in lottery tickets
let's talk about treasure for dogecoin
do you think it's gonna happen in one
tesla for dogecoin yes i think tesla
will accept their choice
in the next six months and the next year
and next year yeah i would actually
i would probably say that with 90
certainty elon musk would be stupid not
to accept
because here's the thing whether or not
they actually keep dogewing he could
just immediately accept it
and sell it off and be done that's what
i would do because when the price
fluctuates 20
and here's the thing too as soon as elon
musk is is
receiving dogecoin now i would imagine
there becomes some some scrutiny on him
or if he's
pumping the price of dogecoin no but i
feel like then it's gonna have to be
he's gonna have to be like more cautious
on his tweets and all that
stuff when it comes to that but it's
free marketing for tesla like i think
for him
it's a no-brainer if he's able to do it
except dogecoin turn around sell it to
me it doesn't matter
but just the fact that you're like ooh
this cool company goes and accepts
dogecoin as payment
i think that would be short-sighted of
them not to question do you think that
that would serve as a catalyst for the
mass adoption
and other companies looking at it damn
tesla is accepting dogecoin
maybe maybe hey guys maybe we should you
know what i mean do you think that's
gonna happen
yeah i think it heightens the chances of
that happening and i think
from there it should right now it's
marketing i mean
no one's doing this because it's like oh
we want to collect dogecoin
they're doing it because guess what they
get exposure yeah i think it's kind of
funny they got a joke but that
ultimately adds value
to dogecoin but for how long and how
much value could be added for how long
the more people have those coin the more
people want to spend i think eventually
it's not gonna be funny anymore
and at that point it's a meme yeah i
know but at some plastic meaning
you met that at some point your original
og me at some
things can only be funny for so long
before at some point they got to stand
on their own and the question becomes
the question it is it's fun now but
gravity listen
i like the i like the movie forrest gump
i really like that movie
but if i watch that movie every single
day for a year i'm going to get bored of
it
it's not going to be fun anymore okay
it's fun wait like here and there you
know i i enjoy it
but i think dogecoin in order to be
actually like taken as a serious
currency you're really used
it can't be the butt of the joke they're
looking but they dodged going like
chipotle
but how cool would that be i i honestly
feel like
memes are the language of our generation
memes are the language of the
millennials and i feel like if we choose
to pick dogecoin as the currency that we
want to use and we put value in that and
we say
this dogecoin right here is worth a
dollar and i want to buy something with
it
and i'm gonna go to 7-eleven and
somebody behind the counter at 7-eleven
is gonna say
i also believe that and i'll take that
as a dollar they're not gonna be saying
that 20 years from now
because it'll probably be about 10 bucks
so it's okay so 10
dogecoin would be a market cap higher
than all the money invested in the
entire market right
so there would be more money more money
yeah so yes if everything else will go
up if jerome powell
prints three times the currency in exit
like like basically if we have the
national debt
held in doge point then maybe 10
dogecoin as possible but i'm just saying
i feel like everything else it wouldn't
be just dogecoin by itself rising it
would be bitcoin would be at a million
dollars or
or ethereum would be at twenty thousand
dollars i don't know like things could
continue to rise and dogecoin is just
like
memes memes or something that are sick
they like a meme comes up and it's funny
remember when the bernie sanders meme
was funny that was hilarious everyone
was talking about it
but it's not funny anymore but it was it
was in the moment but don't give it a
week or two
dogecoin represents means does that make
sense dogecoin is not we're not looking
at it at face value and saying this is
going to go out of style next week
because it represents all the memes it
represents the bernie sanders me it
represents
meme culture in the meme language so i
feel like us using dogecoin as payment
is paying homage to the memes that we
love
every single day i don't know i remember
back when like aol was a thing like
i remember when i was 12 years old going
aol and aol was like the most important
thing
genius thing in the world you'd have
you're like a am on the one side you'd
have
email yet
you remember that you gotta finish you
gotta finish
and your mom would pick up the phone
you'd lose
[Applause]
my friends but you literally get home
from school you go on aim
and you talk with your friends after
school do you remember the first website
you ever went to
uh oh it's probably like pokemon.com the
first website i ever went to
www.beaniebabies.com
and you know how long that took to load
my guy you stare at the screen and it's
like
shoot shoot yeah i hate she would come
back
like you like it wouldn't just pop up it
would like roll it out
it was so exciting it started the top of
the page yeah
you had to wait like a minute or two for
the whole for the whole patient load i
remember i used to go on this side this
website of like reef aquariums
and everyone was posting pictures of
their aquarium on there i would click
the page
and then have to come back 20 minutes
like yes because those pictures would
take so
long to load that especially if it was
like full color pictures or like
like high quality like you would hate to
go to those websites because you'd be
like
damn it like you know what i mean and
here's the thing too believe it or not i
wanted to post my own pictures of my
tank on uh on reef central
and what i had to do i had to get an
actual camera print out the can like put
get those actual pictures developed
scan those pictures jackie's like get
them on the computer
digital cameras digital cameras were
like twelve hundred dollars
they were just coming out so in order to
get a picture on there you had to scan
it
yes
right and there were no videos napster
was like just they were just coming up
you would just barely be able to
download
music but the point being is that back
then that was the thing
aol was untouchable yeah how many people
use aol now
no that that's true that's true nobody
that's true there are things that come
up
that are in the moment revel i mean that
i believe changed like instant messaging
no but you know
if you look at it that was what my space
was though graham like like like
aol was revolutionary for what it was
right then we had to work the kinks out
and somebody else got it yeah gmail
killed it right
yeah okay same thing with myspace
myspace rolled out revolutionary social
media we can
do this we can we can personalize our
page you remember right space
i've never had one do you remember uh
what was it uh live journal
yes yes yes so but i'm but like what my
space for example
i'm 33 okay so yeah okay okay okay
so um so myspace came out it was like
the craziest thing in the world that you
could have your own personal page
and you could like put graphics on it
and then when somebody goes to it they
know you as a person you know what i
mean
uh well they have so many bugs and so
many issues
that they went by the wayside and guess
who who worked out the kinks and fixed
it and made it something that
could be structured and actually works
facebook right
so just because something comes out and
is revolutionary doesn't mean
that you know what i mean like doesn't
mean that it's supposed to last or it
does last
usually most most times it'll come out
it'll shake up the market or whatever
and somebody else will come in and like
make it better
and it'll be like the second or third
time around we'll like figure it out you
know
right but my point being is that i think
that also relates to dogecoin there is a
risk
that dogecoin is revolutionary for the
moment people like it now
give it 10 years and things might change
i would say this if
dogecoin came out two months ago
and was just created and it was this
thing everybody wanted to buy and people
jumped in and people would say hey we're
gonna be millionaires out of this right
i would be super cautious it wasn't
until
i found out about dogecoin a week before
i went all in
so when i found out about it i thought
it was a brand new coin i'm like this
is genius somebody puts a meme on a coin
and now we can buy stuff with it what
but guess what it wasn't brand new but
it wasn't tied to my research i was like
wow this came out in 2013.
that's crazy that means this entire time
it's lasted it's had a backbone it's had
a community behind it it's had people
actually using it
over the years when other
cryptocurrencies that promised things
never did anything but dogecoin was
never supposed to do anything
so i feel like that's the beauty of it
you know what i mean the joke is the
beauty of it
and now we're getting to the point where
it's become
a household name it people know about it
it's on snl it's on ellen's show it's
you know what i mean so dogecoin isn't
new
dogecoin has lasted and showed staying
power so this is something that
i can easily get behind but can it be
what it is today
without the attention if elon musk
doesn't tweet about it if it's not on tv
if we're not talking about it on youtube
can it actually stand on its own
if people forget about it it lasted all
the way up into
january of 2021 without without anything
other than elon's
but the difference is a market cap
difference of a hundred billion dollars
yeah that's the difference but the
difference is an underground rapper
that does open mics down the street
versus drake
like there's a huge difference between
somebody who nobody knows about
versus somebody who now the public knows
about so you're not talking about just
the usa here
we're talking about germany we're
talking about brazil we're talking about
this wouldn't you say mike tyson is
similar to that
went from being an underground fighter
became one of the wealthiest fighters of
all time
then went bankrupt that's a very
specific comparison yeah but you're
making a very specific comparison to
drake
that was a general yeah
superstar artist you know what i mean it
could be drake it could be
j cole it could be yeah we could we
could pick so many different
different athletes or no but he's saying
like a general thing it's like they both
exist
and they're both of the same skill level
but some people know about one and some
people don't yes but but
just like those examples there are other
examples of people who make it big and
then blow it
but that that's within that's that's
more narrowed down that's a narrow down
argument personal thing yes it is it's
his argument but it's narrowed down this
is the thing my argument is
the difference between an underground
rapper that nobody knows about in the
united states doing some shows at open
mics versus somebody who's widely known
whether that's somebody who's widely
known decides to make some bad personal
choices and goes bankrupt or broke
it doesn't matter it could be drake it
could be uh m c hammer was a huge
uh artist in this day and blue at all
like like it doesn't matter what happens
i'm just comparing like
a no-name rapper to a superstar ever
look at almost every stock that's blown
up almost every single one of them if
first of all none of them see thrown ups
of twenty thousand percent none
not one stock unless we're talking about
like a scammy penny stock
maybe in certain examples but almost
none of them stay there
doge is different
yeah it's a currency and that and that
is another issue that eventually the sec
is going to begin regulating this
because because there's very little
there's very little difference between a
currency
and a security the way they're currently
being traded right
very little difference and the only gray
area is that technically these
currencies are decentralized
so there's no one point of contact that
the sec can can force to comply with
regulation
it's the only difference otherwise these
currencies are basically
they're securities this they're wrapped
up securities
as a currency that that's all it is
eventually that's that that this can't
continue
i mean yeah that that's but that's just
across the board though that's with any
crypto like if they're going to
regulate stuff they're going to regulate
bitcoin
there was a court ruling that determined
that bitcoin was a currency
they did not say the same about uh
ethereum
but they ruled that bitcoin is why do
you think that is
uh there's too much involved with
ethereum i think for them to make a
determination
i also heard ethereum's supposed to
crash crazy at some point
which was surprising so so if something
is seen as a
currency by the government is it's taxed
differently than a security
no there's different regulations in
terms of like icos
oh yeah i got it got it right um so as a
security you have to be licensed it has
to be
show through the proper the proper
channels that was the issue with with
ripple is that they determined that
because ripple was a part of its parent
company or like it benefited its parent
company in such an obscure way
that that was treated as a security and
they find uh
and they find the owners of of not the
owners but uh the people who are in
charge i think it was like a 1.2 billion
dollar unlicensed securities exchange it
was some crazy stuff
another thing that uh i talked to um
would meet kevin a little bit was
he asked me why dogecoin specifically
well there's other meme coins there's
other coins that you can use like to buy
and sell things with why dogecoin
specifically right
and i brought up the example of the
mavericks right so so they sell merch
they sell tickets for dogecoin right but
it's not just dogecoin they sell it with
other cryptocurrencies you can buy it
with anything else
so why does mark cuban specify the sales
that he made with dogecoin right
he made he made it sweet saying oh we
sold x amount of whatever for x amount
of dose coins this is incredible this is
great
somebody responded to his tweet saying
why don't you talk about the other
like i bought it with this or i bought
it with this other coin or whatever he's
like
because everyone chooses doge everyone
chooses to use
doge all the other cryptocurrencies are
also available that you can use
to buy merch and tickets but they don't
get used this often you know i'll tell
you because the youtube algorithm is not
promoting those other coins
everyone only cares about doge because
it's marketing
cuban's a great marketer he's on shark
tank he's he's a
good marketer and he acknowledges that
if he has to listen by the way
thank you really good like 20 cents goes
a long way mark cuban is a good marketer
but
that's why he's taking dogecoin okay
it's exposure
i don't think he cares about dojo at all
you don't think so
no why would he buy for his kids it's
fun
it teaches him about investing what did
you say it was teaches
it's fine there we go
but he also had his kid buying game stop
during the whole like this the
little song that's different yeah that's
different but that that's different so
so gamestop running
from like three dollars to 400. that's
different
than dogecoin running up way more 10
times more than that yeah
hedge funds were bleeding you had these
super billionaire people losing money
every time the little guy made money
right
so they had it in their best best
interest to stop that at all cost even
going as far as to doing something
illegal
by disabling the buy button on robin
hood guess what
dogecoin doesn't have hedge funds
dogecoin doesn't really have
somebody losing money when we make money
there's no who
the person who's buying is you're
selling no i'm talking about hedge funds
i'm talking about multi-billionaires
yeah they're shorting that one guy
started shorting dogecoin
you you bet there there's gotta be well
maybe that's not happening now but i'm
saying like okay
well to this point it's it's those coins
had no limit no ceiling and i feel like
the more people get together the more
people
uh come together as a community and
decide to hold and decide to buy and
hold buy and hold
that we're gonna just strengthen this in
numbers and add value to those no
because because in order for the price
to go up it's relying on other people
buying in
at an even higher price but is it not
okay
let's talk about that isn't it the same
way with amazon if i buy an amazon right
now am i paying way more than somebody
that bought amazon 10 years yeah but
with amazon but with amazon you have a
company behind it they're producing
something they're getting
they're getting something you're giving
something of service with
decades of history behind it you're
going
right but but amazon never shot up
twenty thousand percent either i
the the thinking that like objectively i
think we can look at dogecoin at like a
penny
and we could all say it about a penny
okay i don't see a problem with this
the the problem that i see was it goes
from a penny to 70 cents
within a month and all of a sudden in
order to sustain that
it'll require more people to get in and
you're saying there's no losers but the
loser is the person who's buying in at
75
and then it crashes but that's why i
teach people about the dip and then the
first feeling you get
of that first dip everybody has had at
some point when they bought in i had it
i bought it in that four cents do i wish
i got it
under a penny like jack yes would i have
paper handed like a little pansy
no but that's besides the point i'm just
joking but um honestly
the way the way i look at it is i look
at it as the value in dogecoin is not
only getting created by more people
buying
and holding i feel like the value is
also in
other companies accepting it as payment
and so on
but at the end of the day that that is
because more people are buying in and
holding
i mean it's the only thing maybe it's a
synergy thing i don't know but i feel
like at the end of the
at the end of the day six months from
now a year from now two years from now
three like i said when i decided to buy
dogecoin this wasn't a quick flip for me
i wasn't like let me jump in and wait
till it jumps up and
get some more money you know what i mean
like this is a long-term hold i'm
waiting at least a year two
three four or five i feel like this is
in the future there's gotta be people
buying in though
there's gotta be but you gotta be a
loser just like i wanna buy into tesla
today
i'm gonna get it at way higher of a
price than ten years ago that's
gonna be with those going you found out
about it about you found out about it
late so you're paying a little bit more
because you're paying at something that
has more value don't you think there is
a chance
a chance this thing goes back to 10
cents five cents and it stays there and
that becomes the market value 20 years
from now it's trading at 10 cents we all
know
one dogecoin one cent you could go buy
your groceries with it it becomes the
new currency
but it's 10 cents so anything i feel
like if you can buy groceries with it
and you can buy your haircut with it
it's not going to be a cent let's say
okay let's just 15
let's just say i finally ext my money at
15 cents i'm still doing better than i
would buy anything on the stock market
but if you had a chance to sell it today
and make way more money you would have
tripled what it would be at 15 cents
and let's just say what what what if
because you're not there's got to be a
chance with any investment like this
there's a chance that something happens
so i consider that there's a chance
there's there's a small probability
yeah that you're going to break even no
no
no breaking even no maybe 15 cents but
not breaking even
how much of you diamond handing is
principal
versus you wanting to make more money on
your investment at this point it's a
combination i'm going to be honest with
you
i never in a million years thought that
it would get to this level for me
personally like when i got into dogecoin
i thought this was an incredible
opportunity for me to make a lot of
money and change a lot of people's lives
not just my own um now i'm like
looked at as a symbol in a way where i
was a regular regular guy a few months
ago having a nine to five
driving a piece of [ __ ] car you know
what i'm saying like
like i'm anybody down the street and i
was
able to to to be that person and get to
the level that i'm at where now i'm a
millionaire
and it was by buying and holding
dogecoin in a weird way it's like
i feel like people look at me as an
inspiration so
what type of person would i be to look
at my 2.3 million
and just say [ __ ] it i'm out and just
sell it all reasonable i feel like i
would let
so many people down and i feel like
that's a part of it for me
now it's become a part of it but that's
a problem but i have to show that i
because the thing is this do i truly
believe in it yes do i have complete
faith that this is going to go up
yes everything i'm saying is true and
factual now i just have
another reason added on to why i'm done
don't you think that
that cloud's objective thinking to think
that okay i have enough to last me the
rest of my life if i play it smart i'm
never gonna have to work again
that is the message of doge i bet the
popularity that he's gained
just based off dogecoin alone he can
make at least
three times more than that while still
holding not if it goes down
even if it goes down i don't know he's
gonna be like oh
yes they like you how much did he lose
if it how low how how many
loss is the story here is that you
turned 180
into two million dollars if this goes
down if your 180 turns to 500 000 people
do that
daily in the stock market i don't think
there's as much of a story there as
going from 180 to 2 million really daily
in the stock market
from 180 you go to 550 yeah yeah
options happens all the time okay but
i'm just saying like like i don't know
man it's just gotten to a point where i
feel like it's bigger than me
and and this is a just a bigger story
and a bigger narrative and we're talking
about community we're talking about
camaraderie
we're talking about coming together and
changing things the way we see it but it
is it's a bigger deception can change
so quickly but i feel like as long as i
feel like as long as
at the end of the day i'm authentic i'm
real this is my life
and this is truly what i believe in and
how i go about it like i feel like if
people see that and they like
this guy's real everything about this
guy's authentic and he really believes
in this coin and he's gonna hold
until he can't hold any longer and i'm
gonna be right there with him helping
him out because he's helping me out by
staying up there
when i could easily just cash out and
leave you see what i'm saying i don't
know but but
in your example that like any regular
guy can go and become a millionaire with
dogecoin
the same thing could also be spun about
lottery tickets
that i'm a regular guy played the
lottery made a hundred million dollars
me buying the lottery there's no
camaraderie there there's no community
there there's a bunch of people getting
together like hey guys let's go
buy dollars lottery tickets there was
when the lottery had a billion dollars
you should have seen the lines because i
was in the line
everyone was hyping each other out so
there were meetups there were there were
facebook groups like lottery ticket
holders like hey guys who's holding the
lottery ticket let's go i've never
looked into it that much but you got
into any gas stations
every once in a while i'm just saying
starts telling each other what they're
going to spend their billion dollars on
a lottery ticket
it's not the same how about with uh how
about with gambling there there are big
gambling groups out there people
i'm sure they're awesome yeah people who
play crabs together they dissect craps
they okay
people to gamble
are they trying to change the world no
they're just trying to make money
dogecoin is so much more than trying to
make money dogecoin is trying to change
the world
as we see it dogecoin is trying to
change the economy as we see it in the
fiat currency
that we don't like how is it how is
dogecoin doing what
let's say something on the ethereum
blockchain can't do nothing it's just
more fun
[Laughter]
yes i love it yeah that's what it is bro
that's just what it is he's not wrong
he's very right thank you i think it's
fun
now i want to see it fun five to ten
years from now so you think the joke's
gonna wear off
i do i don't think so i don't either man
this is our life this is our
like i said this is the language of our
generation i just i just think
objectively you you got enough to last
forever
that's true sell it people would be very
happy for you to sell it
they i don't know i don't think there's
one i don't think there's one person
people down
i'm with him i feel like i'm letting
people down right
he even felt like at the level that he
was that imagine me you do a better
service to show people as an example of
what happens when you think objectively
you're practically you had a goal in
mind you hit it faster than you
expected you were able to set yourself
up for the rest of your life
and and you played it smart i think that
would be that's a much rarer story
than people who make it big and then
lose it but that's not i don't think
that's the type of person you are
it's not but absolutely not now at the
same time though
i can't sit here and tell people by the
dip
that's funny to say right by the dip
right it's funny right but am i doing it
yes i'm doing it so i can't tell you to
to
to hold diamond hold and then i and then
over here on the corner i'm selling 500
coins or i'm selling a
you know what i mean i can't do that
like that that that's goes against
everything i believe in
so if i'm telling you buy the dip and
then i go and buy the dip at
30 000 coins i bought at 47 cents that's
because
i'm in it for real this reminds me of
late 2017 i had so many friends getting
into all coins and i remember seeing
them
10x their portfolio in a few months
between between the months of like
october
and december everyone was putting in 100
200 000
it was worth like a million and they
lost 95
of it very quickly i do feel like
i do feel like not only is those
different good job jack but i also feel
like
the market is different the world is
different the world wasn't ready for
cryptocurrency in 2017
the world is now ready for
cryptocurrency in 2021 but you're not
but you're not saying critic
the world is ready for dogecoin the
world is ready for crypto and with clear
and with crypto comes doge i mean think
about
how your life has changed in the past
like couple of weeks with dogecoin and
everything
i mean you've gotten like mainstream
because that's what the algorithms the
algorithms right now are
pushing that so so everyone's like yeah
we got nothing wrong
i'll tell you from a youtube perspective
you got you got to strike while the iron
is hot if people want a certain topic
you gotta give them that topic facts and
then but tru attention
goes so quickly and it fades and it's
something else a month from now it's
going to be something else
but though just forever exactly remember
remember when the market
the market dumped the market crashed we
gotta talk
that was every single video for a while
because that's all people want to talk
about and then after a while people was
like
nah it's fine it's fine let's move on to
something else
it's just now it's cryptocurrency it's
so much every every topic has a way for
a month or two and it changes to
something else i'll put it like this
i did not know anything about crypto in
2017.
the first year i heard about crypto was
2017 when bitcoin shot up like crazy
right
that was my first introduction i like to
think i'm pretty hip
to like things happening in the world so
i feel like just the fact that
i didn't know and i know a lot of people
that had no idea what it was and just
got introduced to it because of 2017
plus social media wasn't as ramped up as
it is now there's so many other elements
that almost
came together in 2021 and kind of
aligned that
now is the time that's how i feel i
i mean my position is still to sell
you'll have enough
buy a house cash you're going to tell me
about vegas by the way
i am do we want to talk about that right
now yeah let's talk about vase but we
should also discuss the things that have
been happening in your life oh that's a
lot
you know what let's talk about what's
happening we got because we got a lot of
people behind the scenes
okay let's talk about it we gotta
discuss this
let's talk let's talk about it let's
talk about it so guys it went it started
at it's
okay it started with the cnbc article
with my face in it me going public with
my identity
this dude flipped 180 000
to over a million right because at the
time it was i just cracked the million
it went from that to business insider
reaching out to me to write an op-ed
so i sat down one night eight hours
straight and i just wrote my whole life
down on a google doc and now somebody
isn't that crazy
now somebody there's a senior editor
over at business insider
who's basically writing it with me and
like making it sound professional and
stuff like
that's nuts uh new york times reached
out to me
to do an article with the new york times
what is life
the other day yesterday or the day
before they sent out a photographer to
take a bunch of pictures of me
on my beat up car eating a slim jim like
you know what i'm saying like what is
life bro like this is all really
happening right now in real time
and and then documentary team shout out
to the documentary team uh
uh they reached out to me interested in
my story i sat down did an interview for
about an
hour and they said you know what we want
to tell your story
can you shoot tomorrow we want to we
want to we want to film you waking up
and what you do in your life and
i'm over here juicing celery what you
know what i'm saying like these things
are just happening
and then andre shout outs to andre man
none of this would have been possible
yeah without andre andre thank you so
much
so and he knows this he i say thank you
every chance i get because i would not
be in this position if it wasn't for him
yeah we wouldn't even have been
connected if it wasn't for andre none of
this would happen me
kevin wouldn't have happened you guys
wouldn't have happened um the live
stream
he put his channel on the line shout out
to andre he's never done live streaming
before it could have messed up his whole
channel
he he's over here live streaming snl
they could have just crashed his channel
and and youtube could have messed it up
or whatever he took that chance because
of me
you know what i mean so yes i'm just
grateful man
i'm just yeah
so yeah i'm just thinking so but uh so
so what else is going on besides that
i mean people keep asking me for money
are you serious
that's the worst feeling in the world
man just be happy for me i come forward
who asked you for money random people on
the internet bro
you send me some dollars can you give me
some money please millionaire
i'm like i don't even i'm not i'm the
brokest millionaire you know if you guys
know how much money i had in my bank
account you'd laugh
i got 100 i'll tell you i don't care i
got 130
in my bank account right now don't you
think then it would be a nice idea
i got a paycheck coming in a few days i
know but don't you think it might be a
good idea
my bank account right what are you gonna
today i woke up and this happened this
is because
my both of my credit cards i maxed out
they're put in auto pay
so what happens is they take out the
full amount
at the end of the year at the end of the
month so i have to call the bank and i
have to tell them hey can you please
send that back i don't want to pay the
full amount right now
i'm going to pay minimum amount so this
happened today so i'm still going to
call the bank
yeah i don't care man i'll screenshot
we'll block out any numbers yeah
yeah yeah it's a negative balance of
like 50 400 bucks you don't think it
like you just you you could you could
i'm getting a paycheck no it's right
a little bit off my credit cards i'll be
able to buy some food and
i don't i don't need much man to get by
i'm okay if you
market all of your dogecoin fame and
everything that is way more valuable
than the two million dollars
yes you don't think so yes how much do
you make a year it depends
on youtube bro but it but i i'm not
centered around one thing in particular
i what i would do neither is he click on
him for his personality
as a person not because i would say come
for the dollar stay for the pro
out of 50 let's say andre i'm going to
be honest out of 50 000 people that
watch you i would say probably 90
percent of that is is dogecoin related
i would say you don't think they care
about me i would say 10 i say this for
myself if
i were to post random stuff maybe five
percent maybe 10 at the very most my
audience would actually watch the vlog
yeah the vlog yeah that's about that's
about 10 minutes
yes it is through all through through
all subscribers across
all the players sure through all
subscribers across all platforms
but like no i would say it's like 25 of
your audience
if your main channel videos get three
hundred dollars
but that's with four years of posting
almost every day
four years i'll put i'll put it like
this if i can make what i make at work
right now off of youtube per year
60 grand i'd be happy i would say
potentially doable but i will say that i
believe
10 of your audience will stick around
they will watch anything that you post
so i would think it was everything yeah
my story is
more last week he's made ten grand like
i know if he was monetized by the way
because of dogecoin that fades i have
seen
so many channels but i just said ten
percent but i've seen
so many channels pump up temporarily
they think it's gonna last forever
and they don't i would say that have
nine out of ten channels
never are able to maintain that's good
it takes
persistence and dedicate like i'm not
saying you could do no no no no no yeah
i'm a hard worker bro i know you i feel
like i could like but it would take
a lot to be able to do that it's it's
it's 100 doable
i don't doubt that you'll be able to do
it and i know there are people who would
watch anything that you post because
they
they like you but i would say just but
the thing is i feel like it's it's a
it's a combination of like you said
earlier like
i guess i'm likable whatever i feel like
it's a combination of that
it's a combination of my life story and
coming from nothing
and being a millionaire in 69 days i
feel like it's also a combination of
uh the the lifestyle
video is so i have a video i don't know
if you saw this i have a video
the title of the video is revealing the
car i drive
as a dogecoin millionaire i start the
video have you seen it
it is so funny listen they're great
concepts but i'm just i'm just saying i
don't want to see you losing no no no no
no i get it i get it
i want to see you walk away from this in
a good position
to make money longer i appreciate that
not just right the hype of dogecoin and
i appreciate it because it's not going
to be like like
i've seen this happen so many times i
appreciate that it doesn't last
seriously yeah so i know i know you mean
well and i know
you care about honestly yeah even though
we just met i know like yeah i know you
have good intentions i'm being
the only reason i'm being hard because
like my my biggest fear would be
if something happens to this you're
you're i listen i think chance of you
actually losing money
pretty much non-existent if i were to
bet on it i don't think you're gonna
lose money i think you're 180 500 grand
you know whatever you're gonna make
money yeah but i would hate to see this
die down
your investment goes down to let's say
five six hundred grand let's say after
tax it's you know 450
okay and you're left 450 on something
that
used to be really exciting that people
were all happy about that might take
a long time to get back to this point
during which point
you look back at this you know i could
have sold they could have done this and
that
right now it's like from my perspective
you could lock that in
no it might not be too it's full but you
could lock 80 of it in now
cash out and for the rest of your life
you'll be that dude who who bought
dogecoin became a multi-millionaire from
it
paid off this house was smart with your
money and now you can do anything you
want
that's how i see it and that's like 90
guaranteed
just with a swipe up of a little i feel
like you know
in a weird way i feel like i could do
both i feel like i could be that symbol
for the dogecoin community and not touch
or sell a single coin and then just bust
my
on youtube and just create incredible
content
that not only has to be about those you
could be around those could be about
crypto whatever
and just like work hard like i've worked
hard my entire life 33 years
of living i bust my work really hard to
get to this point
i feel like what's another year or two
on on youtube until i can get to that
level where i'm at a million subscribers
or or 2 million subscribers
and i'm out here pumping out content and
and i hadn't i didn't have to
sacrifice the doge i didn't have to
sacrifice it or sell a single coin
i'm still that for the people but here
i'll also have a successful youtube
channel and i have other ways of making
money
right i'm just gonna say you're you're
the audience is very fickle okay
it's extremely cool right now and i
i just seen it happen so many times or
like right now they're all for you but
one little change for sure dogecoin
drops people
lose money they don't they'll flip a lot
of people playing he sells dogecoin
the likelihood of him becoming a
successful youtuber goes drastically
down what i think it goes up
no i think because he's not going to be
a personal finance youtuber that shows
up
he's a kooky guy that like lives i'm a
kooky guy
but he's always going to be a kooky guy
and but he's going to be the cookie guy
who won
i don't know that's a compliment or what
no i i call myself
he's the guy made money i i think his
chances if he sells
of success long-term go up that's what i
think and you know what
but here's that's crazy i think time
will tell because here's that
neither of us know he's i think he's
taking a bigger risk by not selling
than the guaranteed likelihood of
success long term by selling today
anyway what's going on with vegas for
you vegas man
it was a pleasant trip i i like that
that's the best way for me to put it um
super last minute
you know i i was on the phone with andre
he was like
bro let's do let's do a follow-up video
i'm like all right he was like
i'm booking you a flight one hour let's
go i'm just
throwing my stuff in the back yeah i had
no idea throw myself on my back get to
the airport
fly out there i'm out there we shoot all
he got me a hotel
thank you andre and uh and uh we shoot
all day thursday we meet up with you you
know what i mean we do everything with
you guys
and uh everything's just like new
exciting like different
like like the terrain you know what i
mean just like where you guys live
like the pool even though you don't use
it that much
but as we're coming back to his house
and finishing up and i'm doing
you know the intro with him and outro
and all that stuff um
the documentary team hits me up and
they're like hey
we want to shoot tomorrow morning you
waking up and what you do in your
morning routine and i'm like
i'm in vegas and so literally i'm like
bro i got i'm talking to andre i'm like
bro i gotta go i gotta go now
he books a flight an hour later and and
i'm throwing everything back in my bag
whoopty whoop get get get into the uh he
he like
bee lines and speeds all the way to to
the airport i get at the airport
my flight ends up getting delayed and
all this crazy stuff i don't get home
until like
1am or 2am or something crazy and i got
to be up at like
six a.m because the the documentary team
is coming at eight a.m
and my place is a mess so i gotta clean
up i gotta vacuum i gotta put everything
in order put everything they gotta
shower i gotta look good you know what i
mean like i got you know
i think it was better if you left
bro i'm brazilian we're hospitable as
hell
so if i have any person coming to my
house that place has to be a spotless my
guy
like my mom is a house cleaner to this
day you know what i mean so so like
she'd be so disappointed in me she's
just looking at this documentary he's
like
you need to put your clothes away you
know what i'm saying like but but yeah i
had to do all that and be ready for them
when they got there and it's just been a
roller coaster
ride man like i'm so thankful for
literally everything i'm just
i'm that guy who just is happy to be
here
i'm just happy to be here are you gonna
move to vegas
i'm seriously considering so like like
it's so funny because i was telling jack
this off camera bro
vegas never even crossed my mind until i
made money
you know it's like ugh la isn't that
great anymore you know what i mean like
i got to get
out of here like i gotta go to texas or
vegas or whatever
vegas you'll be in your andre and i man
i would love that i would seriously love
that you guys have been
like the greatest honestly like thank
you yeah seriously i want to make oh i
want to make sure this turns out well
for you man i'm like i'm i
just i'm i'm worried i'm worried that's
what everybody's worried about that's
how i feel
i'm like did you say hey honey did did
you sell yet
no you still hold on oh you should you
know what
you should do you should like have
little like little uh
every once in a while like hit me up and
call me like hey hey pro where you at
what's your portfolio looking like oh
you didn't sell all right then i'll uh
check in with you little later okay how
are you doing yeah
saw the price stop blowing it on tv
it's not so happy about that oh man
i just okay that's funny i just want to
make sure this turns out well either way
this this this is one of the episodes
this is the movie really fun to look
back on yes five years from now yes
because i think
even even like short term with bitcoin
there's so many times you look back at
it okay it went to 3500 looks terrible
for it and
yeah a few years later so this is this
will be one of those episodes we got to
look back on
way in the future yeah i want people to
know that i'm doing it for myself
and i'm doing it for the people and i'm
doing it for the community and i want us
all to win at the end of the day all
right i would i would just say
first and foremost you got to take care
of yourself because that's how you're
able to take care of other people so
i want you to lock in and sell two
million profit i know you do
i love it yeah love you too i have a
question yeah
if you could sell right now at a one
dollar price point per dogecoin
would you do it at a dollar after about
the 30 000 coins i'm officially oh this
is great i get to tell you oh you have 4
million i'm officially at 4 million
though congratulations
thanks guys so so at a dollar i'm a 4
millionaire
which would be crazy and you would sell
or no you didn't like if you sold that
dollar you would never be able to buy
back in and i'd continue all day
until that's serious so so so this is my
thing okay i tell everybody this
it's either one year from my from my
dogecoin purchase
or when i hit 10 million so if a year
from today i'm not at 10 million let's
say i'm at 2 million 3 million 4 million
i'm gonna take out 10 percent because i
have so many things i want to accomplish
in life like i said i have the rap
uh label that i want to do i have the
rap music media content that i want
there's so much stuff we didn't talk
about
still have and you and you you fund all
of it sell half
you're set that's the other thing that's
why not
i just i just that way it's the best of
both worlds
it's not one or the other it's not black
and white you sell two million of them
today
you guarantee you lock that in that's
yours that's not going anywhere that's
right the other half
yellow white you're still the same
dogecoin person you're still
the same same what do you say cookie
you're still the same i'm the dogecoin
guy but you sold half
you know those were able to accomplish
everything you wanted to talking about
kooky guy you know you know
the funniest comment that i read under
one of my videos somebody was like
i swear somebody is paying this guy
to not get a haircut well you get a
haircut if doug corn hits a dollar
i'll get a haircut okay can you take the
hoodie it's not
this is guys this is you know what i
think the hair makes it though look at
this
like i just screamed doge don't i i like
i screamed
you know what you know what would be
interesting i would love for a video
we do like a makeover sort of thing have
you seen that
yeah you should shave the beard it looks
so
really nice like i'm actually put on a
suit yeah put on a suit and like do one
of those things that we take yet for
dinner
let's do it let's do a let's do a
makeover i'm down we do actually
actually do that i'll do it window just
a dollar
because i was thinking this would be a
fun video for the for the how do you
know for the vlog yeah
for the vlog for giving me the
millionaire haircut yeah makeover
if you want to do that we'll fly you to
talk about it i'll we'll fly you to
vegas
okay i'll pay for the haircut i'll pay
for the shave okay i'll pay for
a uh uh not not expensive
like i want a professional given give me
a haircut like like one of those nice
professional shaver sort of deals yeah
um get you like a like a reasonable suit
like a men's warehouse
okay like you know i mean guys let us
know in the comments section down below
would you like to see me get a haircut
yes or no
what about the beer would you like me to
cut it let me know
what about the pool will you hear that
for me exactly if you'll split the cost
with me
wow you're gonna be using the pool more
than that see
if you guys didn't know this we haven't
heated up the pool at the vegas house
and why is that graham
it's 200 bucks i have a feeling you guys
used the pool once and it was for that
one youtube video you did when you lost
the dogecoin oh yeah
yeah i didn't eat it for that that's
graham he spent how much on the pool
uh like a hundred grand by the way i
died laughing at that when i saw that
when i first watched your video i was
like
yeah i said in in in this video that i
filmed with you i said if the video gets
100 000 likes again i'll
do i'll fall back in the pool okay let's
do it so
unheated by the way only doge though
yeah thanks for getting intense for that
i thought you were about to like beat
jacob
paper-handed pants it's all good though
jack you should change your uh instagram
paper no paper-handed should i do it you
should know
you gotta do you gotta change your
instagram uh about me because it says
like dogecoin
oh dogecoin entrepreneur yeah you can't
say it's gotta say
yeah okay and then with the price you
sold dogecoin at
so yes yes yes people need to know
that's gotta be cemented
so with that said you guys thank you so
much for watching i really appreciate it
as always make sure to destroy the like
button subscribe button and notification
bell
also feel free to add us on instagram
our information is down below in the
description and don't forget
you get a free stock worth all the way
up to 50 dollars
using the link down below in the
description i know that's public.com
facts that's it thanks enjoy thank you
so much for watching and until next time
subscribe to the clips channel and
subscribe to pro oh yeah the dogecoin
millionaire
pro to doge check me out on social media
follow me
let's go let's go to the moon to the
moon
i'm your boy doge and we have made and
then i write and i say yeah okay